the future of humanity seems insecure
rapid climate change political division
our greed and failings make it hard to
look at our species with a lot of
optimism and so many people think our
end is in sight
but humans have always thought they
lived in the end times every generation
assumes they're important enough to
witness the apocalypse and then life
just goes on
this is a problem because it leads to
short-term thinking and prevents us from
creating the best world for ourselves
and our descendants what makes this
worse is that we may actually be living
at an extremely critical moment in human
history
to understand why let's look at the
temporal window of humanity and ask
when will the last human be born and how
many people will there ever be
[Music]
these sorts of estimates come with a lot
of uncertainties so please take them
with a gigantic grain of salt
to get a sense of how many people there
will be let's see how many people have
already lived
modern humans arose some 200 000 years
ago
they were uniquely good at making tools
telling stories thinking abstractly
planning and working together in large
groups beyond their close family
still there were not that many of us
surpluses of food were scarce survival
was hard life expectancy was low
it took us 150 000 years to grow to a
population of 2 million
improvements were gradual and eventually
led to the agricultural revolution
arguably the biggest change in our
history
this was when our numbers really started
growing it took 10 000 more years to get
to 300 million
but that increase was dwarfed by the
industrial revolution in 1800 there were
a billion of us
the human population doubled in just 120
years and then again in 50.
today we number around 8 billion
in total over the last 200 000 years
about 117 billion humans were born and
lived and 109 billion also died
which means that about seven percent of
all humans that ever lived are alive
right now as many as were born in the
first 150 000 years of human history
every minute 270 babies join the party
but there aren't just more people never
before have we been as healthy and well
off or lived longer
with growing living standards our birth
rates collapsed
the un estimates that around the year
2100 we will hit our population peak and
there will be 125 million people born
each year
it's pretty unlikely that birth rates
will stay stable forever but let's
pretend to make our thought experiment
simpler
how many people there will be in the
future depends on when our species will
die out and here we find a lot of
uncertainties
we are able to destroy ourselves through
our own inventions but we are also able
to find solutions to avert catastrophic
risk
we can change the direction of planet
killer asteroids but we've also invented
nuclear weapons
we discovered antibiotics but also carry
diseases across the globe in a matter of
days
our industrial system gives us an
incredible standard of living but also
change the atmosphere in the process
it's very hard to say if human ingenuity
will prolong or shorten our species
lifespan if things go badly our end
could come suddenly but if we managed to
avoid that we could conceivably stick
around for a long time
so every day we don't destroy ourselves
may mean life for an unfathomable number
of humans
how many people are we talking about
it depends on how far our species is
going to expand
scenario 1 humans will never leave earth
if we stay on our home planet a good
metric to look at is the extinction rate
of animals that we get from the fossil
record
the average lifespan of mammalian
species is in the region of 1 million
years with some surviving up to 10
million years
our close relative homo erectus survived
for about 1.9 million years
let's be conservative and assume that
humans will survive for a million years
which leaves us 800 000 more years to
dawdle away assuming a stable birth rate
of 125 million people each year this
means there are roughly 100 trillion
humans waiting to be born
850 times greater than the number of
people that have ever lived
this would make everybody alive today
only
0.008 percent of all people that will
ever live
think about where this leaves you
instead of putting you at the end of the
chaotic mess that was our past it would
mean you live at the very beginning of
something big
the start of the human story rather than
the end
doesn't this feel incredibly different
and now consider that this may be an
extremely pessimistic estimate
if we match the survival time of the
most successful mammals then our future
numbers rise to 1.2 quadrillion people
that have yet to be born
and even this seems far from our
potential as the sun slowly gets hotter
and brighter earth will remain habitable
for about 500 million years giving so
many more potential people the chance to
become actual people
and now let's begin to think big
scenario two
humans will leave earth
we went from humans worshiping the moon
to humans walking on it so who knows how
much further we can go
if we don't die out within the next few
hundred years ideas that seem outlandish
right now become serious considerations
if we believe that we have a chance of
surviving for maybe millions of years
then we could expand onto the other
planets or into our own artificial
worlds
life needs three things a surface
resources and energy
our sun provides energy for billions of
years and there is so much water and
material floating in the asteroid and
kuiper belt that we could sustain many
times our current population
instead of living on planets we could
decide to construct our own artificial
worlds and habitats
with resources and energy so abundant we
could try out different types of society
and ways of life
an interconnected civilization spanning
the solar system would create the basis
of existence for an absurd number of
individuals orders of magnitude more
than if we stick to earth even if we
only existed for a few million years
this future doesn't have to be grim and
dark as science fiction likes to paint
it
with quadrillions of people waiting to
be born we will have billions of doctors
working on curing cancer billions of
problem solvers working on ending
poverty and billions of video game
developers making life fun
more humans may actually mean more
progress
another upside of leaving earth and
spreading out is that it becomes much
harder for us to become extinct as you
need a solar system-wide catastrophe to
catch everybody
so aside from nearby supernovae or
gamma-ray bursts humanity would be
relatively safe from extinction maybe
for billions of years
if we managed to survive for that long
slow evolution or genetic engineering
might split us into multiple species or
we might intentionally keep ourselves
the same as we are now
so to account for that we'll just talk
about people from now on instead of
humans
okay now let's think really big
scenario three people leave the solar
system
as enormous as the solar system is it is
just one star system among billions in
the milky way
if future people can colonize say 100
billion stars and live there for 10
billion years with each generating 100
million births per year then we can
expect something like a hundred
octillion lives to be lived in the
future this is a one with 29 zeros 100
000 trillion trillion
we can spend this up as much as we like
the andromeda galaxy will merge with the
milky way adding another trillion stars
for us to settle
red dwarfs stay active for up to a
trillion years and future civilizations
might even find energy for their
habitats around black holes
a sufficiently advanced civilization of
our descendants might even try to reach
other galaxy groups
while these numbers are mind-blowing
they may underestimate the number of
unborn people by many orders of
magnitude
if we divide the total energy available
in a galaxy by the average energy needs
of a single person then we get a treat a
zillion potential lives
a million trillion trillion trillion
potential people
conclusion
hopefully what's become evident is that
if we don't kill ourselves in the next
few centuries or millennia almost all
humans that will ever exist will live in
the future
which brings us back to us in the
present
we exist at a high point in human
history with incredible possibilities at
our grasp
technological environmental and societal
what we do matters for all the people
who do not exist yet
so while it's not on vogue to think
about humanity's long-term future with
optimism or to think about it at all
maybe this has given you a bit of
perspective
if we screw up the present so many
people may never come to exist
quadrillions of unborn humans are at our
mercy
even if we go with fairly conservative
estimates the unborn are by far the
largest group of people and the most
disenfranchised
somebody who might be born in a thousand
or even a million years deeply depends
on us today for their existence
this is why it's important to think
about the distant future and why our
presence is so crucial why it matters
what we do today
one day the last human will be born we
don't know when but if we change our
perspective from us living at the end of
the human story to us living at the very
beginning we can not only build a
wonderful world for us and for them
but also for countless numbers of others
huge announcement we're launching
kotzkuzak in six more languages arabic
brazilian portuguese french hindi
japanese and korean on top of our
english german and spanish channels
bringing new perspectives and a love for
science to as many people as possible
especially to some languages that are
underserved because it's not profitable
to translate to
if enough people watch our new channels
we can hopefully run them for many years
to come
this is where we need your help
it takes us a lot of time effort and yes
money to translate our videos properly
and run so many channels so to make this
sustainable please help us spread the
word
if you're native in one of these
languages share our videos on social
media and tell your friends and family
make people in your native language
aware that it exists
this multi-language expansion is
supported by open philanthropy an
organization that tries to do as much
good as possible they want to help us
spread awareness of science and ideas
for how you can help humanity thrive
their values align with ours in many
fundamental ways so we're going to work
with them on more projects in the future
so please help us spread the word and
thank you for watching
[Music]
wait
[Music]
you